e aí galera que aceite meu canal trombou
com vocês como você está hoje em nesta
manhã
nesta tarde e noite não sei que você
está assistindo - e nem de onde você
está assistindo e pode estar assistindo
aqui do brasil como angola galera angola
que me assiste muito obrigado você que
me acompanha um beijo a todos os
angolanos está rolando aí acontecendo
mais uma vez big brother é o big blog
para dar coisa é meu amigo para assunto
porque eu não sei se bill broonzy só que
o big brother que chega até você se não
quiser assistir para saber que todo
mundo fala só fala disso pouca ano 8 mil
de arroz élvio um programa caro o pai da
menina cada um beijo a boca ancara
acredita em erro na mesa o que importa
na admissão acontece quase um padrão
seja o tipo a televisão inventa coisas
vai passar novas pessoas cara quando fez
melhor que o povo seja essas coisas que
ela é isso que acontece aí e quem sair
não sei cartões de natal bem de noite o
fich para sair do banheiro onde eu você
e eu não assisti big brother mas eu já
assisti uma vez que o big brother hoje
não está mais como é my big brother e
foi beber faz tem hoje em dia ficou tão
fácil mas lá dentro antigamente big
banda galera de abstinência porque
fumava ficar doidos semana sem fumar já
estava tinha meu deus é o trânsito ficar
mandando eu o meu cigarro eu sou meu
cigarro é a pessoa da abstinência tirar
o desinfetante ou nunca' fuma do big
brother então esse é o intuito o
isolamento a galera ficava muito doida
ativamente por brigada por chutar as
áreas o que vai pegar o xampu quem foi
que pegou o meu xampu o show foi a noite
pegar só um pouquinho já no galeão
poente girl permissão para pegar o meu
xampu onde interessa um gol que mudou é
chata bacana aí ele falou o que chamo
tudo isso como é chupar cana prova de
resistência política era 8 dia cabo só
ficava com uma mão pra cima no poste
quanto a morrer ao bial falava asa de
frango é nadia linha sequer assistiu
bebê dá uma risadinha em vai quem fica
lepetit popular nesse café chocolate os
participantes já estão há oito dias na
prova de resistência vão olhar como
estão num
william é um pouco de água ea gente se
despede por hoje nossas lojas estão
quase morrendo
mas antes vamos dar aquela espiadinha e
[ __ ] se beber chá morrerem quer seu lixo
hoje na prova hoje a prova do líder e
qual é a cor que é parecido com a fruta
vermelha em maçã em laranja parabéns ao
seu novo livro ganhou uma casa em barra
de ouro que vale mais do que uma casa a
imagem do ex bota galera muito
selecionada é sempre assim é sempre
assim o homem é bonito o no homo é
normal uma vector do bebop ou veta o big
fone
ele diz isso quem engana o ferramenteiro
uma bruxa meu até o bruxo botar bruxa de
blair é ter da casa que ela falava em
colocar quem é que ele não gostava de
cavalo ela falava com essa voz assim com
essa voz de bebê que ana paula fazendo
voz de bebê eo namorado dela como o
cazaque a top para tocar e eu gosto
camisa é top ele esse cara tem que
ganhar tudo em um sermão bonito você
seguir a vida e fazer as coisas cara é
[ __ ] cara tá com dor de cabeça acho vou
na minha cabeça do empossando vacas de
que isso nada sou cabeça é bom ter essa
dor de cabeça tem que fazer por levanta
por buda vai fazer as coisas protege nem
cabeça
ontem à noite matou cansada cansada de
cabeça pode ficar cansado porque tem que
fazer o que sei que vocês vão fazer por
cansava já deu trégua latas gravava bota
na boca como goiaba é muito bom e ele
fica preocupado com ele mesmo que ele
está comendo muita goiabada sair vai
fazer mal vai no confessionário fifa.com
muitas lojas não é bom pra fazer e
aberto em mim o hedge é tranquilo tá de
boa ele é pop uma mudança não pode ouvir
música universal dando a clara parabéns
a você eu casar foi a loja estava na
casa casar
naiara azevedo pode o padre fabiano
jataí uma cor de antigamente hoje em dia
que não bate garante o artista aí é só
podia cantar porque nem falar hoje em
dia o cara passa na corda dança junto
com o cantor lucas salatta poeta pessoas
não eu nunca já é o novo anel princesa o
príncipe já tá aí
outra diferença de idade de 8 e brighi
blog antigamente o povo morri de
vergonha e meu deus vou tá assistindo a
gente de hoje o projeto a casa vota na
roupa fora sim eu entrei e um deixem só
pelé não sei se eu posso que eu tenho
uma pessoa lá fora então deixou porque
com ele foi morna e fego não vai ter
esse caso do lucas que é o noivo é na
loja israel porque naquela briga
vagabundo de ver um cara é noivo a
mulher está esperando de fora e não
aparentou estar louca não tinha nem vai
contratar maloca fazer sucesso na casa
porque o pablo cuesta empreendendo de
geladeira o outro nada pensei na um
irmão que estava a menina tá botando pra
cima do cara o canon entendeu sassá a
mulher sair por aqui fora a menina
estava tanto a espanha pega os sonhos ou
pessoa
o país porque tá acabamento machista nós
está como se agora como fosse da mulher
porque um cara noivo vaca ponto trair a
mulher ainda uma noiva por isto papo
circunstância - big brother brasil dae
no key da chapa estava atraia punha
campo e tem o batom e talvez se outras
pessoas não traz nenhum e agora agora em
barber pessoa minha mulher agora pronto
agora
agora estou é o prefeito de ouro do
mundo não são perguntas que está errado
essa situação é o carro é a mulher meu
patrão beber mais jovem está certo e
quem está errado eu não sei quem é não
também cada um resolver sozinho e falar
depois eu sei que quem toma no top de
linha é noivo que tanto do lado de fora
da casa ea minha mulher agora pronta
estamos acompanhando aqui pelo estado em
alfinetar e vamos ver o que aconteceu
com certeza o lucas porque dela certeza
não está vendo aqui mais uma merda do
noivo aconteceu ela bloqueou celular
então é assim né um homem não presta não
está aqui é porque o homem no prédio
rappa o que eu tenho a ver com cavaco
o negócio tem nada a ver com isso não
vivo 60 e depois de eleito já samuel
mesmo com um possível briga também
getúlio número eo rapaz e tá vendo lá eu
estou lá dentro por acaso você está a
ficar falando mas como é tudo a mesma
merda aí - a carta bento a fazer isso
com a noiva dele você faria isso comigo
amor primeiro de tudo bonito no sul
nesse caso segundo mas eu vou um
programa que eu nasci terceiro todos
usam noção essa merda toda lá o casal
não está que existe uma pessoa que pega
mesmo vai perceber o hotel caesar na
moral pra mim um outro é muito bem na
pele se casar me salva e que ganhar
escala a por face à então tem que tirar
lucros ou a jéssica para não acontecer
uma [ __ ] e não acontece e gente tem
que ter de gente chegando à conclusão já
a gente acha dever é a [ __ ] um dos
primeiro dia de big blog o pai deu um
beijo na boca da filha maior for o uso
maior portaria a audiência caiu eu fui
levantar o povo gosta de ver a desgraça
acontecendo como eticamente dos
primeiros big brother pessoa morria de
medo no rio de janeiro esteja de ter que
votar em alguém porque é todo mundo
amigo no começo galera fica o meu deus
eu vou votar
botou na no guião mas por questão de
afinidade mesmo que eu conheci o mano
que dê tudo é o menos conhecido programa
maria seu voto hoje maicon joão pedro
que ele pegou um xampu hoje a galera já
entra já junta quatro pessoas a gente
tem que tirar o fulano de tal é muito
forte e tem uma lábia onde tive que
tirar ele pessoa aí vai votar votar num
ciclo ano porque eu achei muito falso
com a gente nem falso keima luca também
conheço o cara tá com uma semana ao k eu
queria botar naná fulano porque eu acho
que ela foi muito grossa na forma que
ela passou o pão hoje de manhã em honra
a ai meu deus vou casar
hoje eu quero votar em mim porque eu
acho que nós juntos vão botar pessoas
têm que lutar casas do que lutar eu
quero votar nem mesmo poder contar as
pessoas podem fazer mal a ninguém que eu
gosto das pessoas tem que fazer por
votar a cabo a cadeira vaga boa como a
goiabada é isso né gente não fique no
instagram da mulher do cara ficar
comentando boston medo cá a jéssica lá
dentro da casa chama de vagabunda que em
seu quê de que dá incendiou minou a o
cara isso cara aqui não sei que preciso
essas coisas embora se esticasse xuxa
deixa o pessoal se resolver para lá e
faz que também se quisesse em garching
um problema papo news e necuto fazer
exibido nessa ficha não se esquece
clicarem gostei aqui no vídeo se
inscrever no canal que nunca perdeu um
vídeo novo e é isso aí valeu como junto
casaca presidente